now Shannon had just finished developing
his theories related to cryptography and
therefore was well aware that human
communication was a mix of randomness
and statistical dependencies letters in
our messages were obviously dependent on
previous letters to some extent and in
1949 he published a groundbreaking paper
a mathematical theory of communication
and in it he uses Markov models as the
basis for how we can think about
communication and he starts with a toy
example imagine you encounter a bunch of
text written in an alphabet of a B and C
perhaps you know nothing about this
language though you notice a seemed to
clump together while B and C's do not he
then shows that you could design a
machine to generate similar looking text
using a Markov chain and he starts off
with a zero order approximation which
means we just independently select each
symbol a B or C at random and form a
sequence however notice that this
sequence doesn't look like the original
he shows then you could do a bit better
with a first-order approximation where
the letters are chosen independently but
according to the probability of each
letter in the original sequence so this
is slightly better as AAS are now more
likely but it still doesn't capture much
structure the next step is key a second
order approximation takes into account
each pair of letters which can occur and
in this case we need three states the
first state represents all pairs which
begin with a the second all pairs up
begin with B and the third state all
pairs that begin with C and notice now
that the a cup has many AAA pairs which
makes sense since the conditional
probability of an a after an a is higher
in our original message now we can
generate a sequence using this
second-order model easily as follows we
start anywhere and pick a tile and we
write down or output the first letter
and move to the cup defined by the
second letter then we pick a new tile
and repeat this process indefinitely
notice that this sequence is starting to
look very similar to the original
message because this model is capturing
the conditional dependencies between
letters
and if we want to do even better we
could move to a third order
approximation which takes into account
groups of three letters or trigrams and
in this case we would need nine states
but next Shannon applies this exact same
logic to actual English text using
statistics that were known for letters
pairs and trigrams etc and he shows the
same progression from zeroth order
random letters to first-order
second-order and third-order sequences
he then goes on and tries the same thing
using words instead of letters and he
writes the resemblance to ordinary
English text increases quite noticeably
at each depth indeed these machines were
producing meaningless text though they
contained approximately the same
statistical structure you'd see in
actual English Shannon then proceeds to
define a quantitative measure of
information as he realizes that the
amount of information in some message
must be tied up in the design of the
machine which could be used to generate
similar looking sequences which brings
us to his concept of entropy
you